one of my dear friends was on fresh and
fit podcast and it was fascinating it
was like Oneness colliding with the
Matrix and I'm excited to play it and
break some of it
down okay so so now you're doing it
through through the lens what religion
do you follow what religion I don't
follow religion I surrender to God no
I'm not spiritual either I I I'm
surrendered to God and God only the one
infinite Creator wait
that's all right so you already have the
Nugget of one infinite Creator it's
breaking the box of religion already off
the bat okay it's breaking the dividing
mind's tendency to want to create a
box energy and all that stuff no I'm not
spirituality all relig so not even
spirituality and all Paths of
spirituality fall into that but I'm not
all paths and religions fall into that
um dividing myself in anything because
I've see the Oneness of all religions
and all spiritual paths that's not
dividing because I see the Oneness of
all religions and spiritual paths okay
and you can see some of the
mind's Machinery in the guests that have
not yet expanded Consciousness to that
kind of place yet are very rolling eyes
uncomfortable that kind of
thing still living in the dream of
Separation spirituality
baby what do you call that denomination
what do you call that like and then
there's the question
so so this is fresh and then who's
asking the question here on the right
and then myON is the one across from him
and they're the two
co-hosts so he asks about denomination I
guess I call it God I don't have a god
surrender practice is God surrender is
not a
belief what Den what
denomination God surrender is not a
belief you just say a spiritual reality
you don't identify under any religion
then Spirit okay that was a closest
we've gotten so far you don't identify
under religion Spirit doesn't need to be
spiritual okay what book do you read
what book do you read and there it goes
again the dividing mind always trying to
box what book do you read what book do
you
read Bible Quran I have Bible Quran let
me me put you in a box because that's
the only way that I know how to be is by
boxing and separation and dividing
things direct so something indivisible
is going to reflect back
indivisibility which is how that
building of new Earth for the abundance
and prosperity of
allignment with God therefore I
don't he's talking to you right now
telling you [__] be feminine
[__] that's actually
true
that
youo God formul it different he didn't
say like be be feminine he said uh you
don't have to be masculine you're safe
you don't have to protect yourself I'm
protecting you you can be in your
natural feminine Essence and then I was
like
okay you are po
Puffs and she came on communicating
about a new school for the feminine to
learn about surrender and to learn about
the Divine Union with the masculine and
together in harmony being able to build
this new Earth
and it's ironic so ironic because the
fresh and fit podcast is also interested
in understanding and promoting in ways
the traditional feminine and yet at the
same time it has all of these Tendencies
with for example so many women that are
are on only fans or here there was a
woman here to to the left she's
in so she this this woman for example
right here at one point in the
podcast she's married and the guys were
doing a rating of the women on a scale
of 1 to 10 in terms of their
attractiveness and they asked her to
they asked everyone to do this to stand
up and and turn
around and she's married and so they
asked her to do it and then she agreed
to do it so the very nature of it is in
fact a contradiction in some ways and so
this is the whole episode had so many
interesting Dynamics like this but this
specifically this like 5minute segment
on Oneness colliding with the Matrix is
the one that we'll highlight
here did you hear that question also do
you do mushrooms right so there's that
question it's almost like the dividing
mind asks about psychedelics because it
has glimpsed the
indivisible and it wants to ask about
okay can we maybe have a little bit of
time to dive into maybe the nature of
psychedelics and how that points to this
indivisibility and there just wasn't it
didn't arise there but you can see it
kind of try to get its Glimpse to expand
more up
mans you had when you were saying
through God or whatever I was like okay
cool what religion do you follow and
then it's like the you said all
religions in one I was like yeah bro
that was it you the moment you said all
religions are one I'm out you see the
dividing mind can't help but create a
box create distinctions create
separation and therefore it overlooks
the indivisible it continuously
overlooks the indivisible into boxes and
Division and that's where then all of
that separation and all of that anxiety
and all of that
unfulfilled and whatnot and it's and
it's also fascinating because it's the
very nature of what God this infinite
Creator is playing with itself here
through these masks when the body itself
is
contracted its nerves its muscles are
contracted into just being the mask
that's actually also such a beautiful
crucial part of the game game is to in a
sense completely Overlook the
indivisibility of everything because
it's what makes the game actually fun
it's what makes the game enjoyable is
the experience of waking up out of the
mask and falling asleep in the mask that
whole thing is so fascinating and those
Worlds Collide just like in this
video I honor Prophet Muhammad okay
close uh uh let me guess and Jesus too
absolutely AB uhhuh so Prophet Muhammad
and let me guess Jesus too right so that
means okay but you have to pick one of
the two and she responds absolutely she
G you can't mix the two together you
can't mix the two together like that you
see it's as
though it's just such an attack
attachment to uh division that you can't
possibly uh understand or be excited
about the teachings of Buddha or about
the teachings of Jesus or Muhammad or
shamanic psychedelic ceremony you you
have to pick one if you don't pick one
then you're now all of a sudden uh I
can't handle it you know that's
reflection that's coming back from the
that contracted energy which is that I
can't deal with your
indivisibility I have to live in the
world of
division because because okay hold on
all the abrahamic pro prophecies are in
my heart and I live them I live through
them but I do not do they talk to you
too who the prophets no only you talk to
me
oh that you were talking to me so I'm
just giving it back your favor yo say
say that word real quick I have an
intuition and I have a very strong
intuition this is so fascinating there
was a a blue screen that happened at
this point and this is such a classical
quote you know breaking of the the
natural pattern it's like a glitch I
love this it's like a glitching because
Oneness is colliding with the Matrix
right now the indivisibility is
colliding with what is contracted and
constantly dividing and that sense of
dividing is always unfulfilled it's
always unfulfilled and it's always
chasing
something and it's chasing
it
some usually in the form of
objectification
and so it's it's actually very selfish
that way whereas what is being shared
here is that through
indivisibility through Oneness there's
already fulfillment there's already
wholeness right and therefore one can
easily be a selfless vessel for building
the new Earth you see that's the key you
can be a selfless vessel for building
the new
Earth you see when you come from
indivisibility from wholeness you
obsolete the
selfishness and you can build new Earth
from that place the constitution of the
body is effortlessly directed towards
that you see basic needs prosperity for
all abundance with energy food
water
housing Joy well-being art creativity
science engineering in all those
things whereas that feeling of division
and separation and lack and
unfulfilled it will always be selfish
and
objectifying and I feel that that is
divine so I I feel that that is God and
I am not placing any
intermediates between me and God
so I love it the BL screen comes right
when intuition this channel this flow of
indivisibility has no
intermediate there's no intermediate
left there's no
Outsourcing the current of
indivisibility that's running through
the
body so there's no more
intermediary
so there's no
more icon or Idol or out
Outsourcing anymore there's no more
objectification of getting something to
fill what is unfulfilled because there
is only indivisibility and wholeness and
unification and love and therefore
selflessness and building new Earth to
the Quran whenever I feel like doing
that I'm I'm I'm reading she did she did
that [__] see yeah she made us go blue
screen here we go all right d we're back
not B like rolling this tripping right
now the vibration went too high and then
uh yes it went too
high and there she says it the vibration
went too high you know there it is
Oneness is colliding with the Matrix
here you see and that's where you get
that that blue screen it's so perfect
it's
soah it's so
perfect you start mixing Gods just
vibrations and everything still here
it's like youx theet with the God and
then you I feel like you need to
organize your ideas first before you
want
to I love it when they from when the
dividing mind tries to give the
indivisible a
reflection our girls in America that
[__] you talking about only you have to
get what you call that [__] organized
you got to get organized you've got to
get more organized basically get more
contracted
yeah I feel like you're exposing you're
talking about something that you don't
really
comprehend I live in a world of division
and you're talking about
indivisibility and therefore I project
that you don't understand what you're
talking
about oh yeah cuz you don't want to be
confused and everybody in the class be
pissed when you want when you want to
become a teacher I'm sorry I'm speaking
I'm sorry when you want to become a
teacher when you want to become a coach
you need to understand exactly what
you're talking about because you have to
think about you're teaching like a kid
you know if you want to become a coach
you need to be able to teach that kid
right in the simplest way and there's so
much overlooking that's happening right
now that the one that is speaking is
unable to detect that they themselves
are the kid that is receiving the
transmission of
indivisibility okay what you want to
transmit and right now we're grown
people we've been to school and I do not
understand honey I'm a doctor I'm
confused right now I love that we are
grown I've been to school I'm a doctor
and I don't understand and that's
exactly what's being reflected is that
the schools are themselves The Matrix
they themselves are that
contractive Weaver into separation into
lack into unfulfillment into division
into divisibility and there therefore
you pop out the other side of school in
a world of separate
people and in a world of lack in a world
of being unfulfilled and therefore your
entire life becomes
objectification so it's a complete loss
apparently of the
indivisibility of the Oneness itself and
so it's just so fascinating that the
very idea of am schooled and I should
understand what you're saying is
actually not applicable here because
it's actually the in many ways the exact
opposite that
the woof woof woof meow meow meow
meow the non-conceptual the
unschooled the innocence of a baby the
innocence of a dog or a c chat that
innocence is actually what can grock the
indivisibility you
see we need a school so we
can you you need to teach it there comes
the projection you need help also very
common that when there's the uh clear
indivisibility that what division says
is you need help you you need you need
to go to school understand what you want
to teach and then teach yeah you need to
go to
school you guys want to put me into a
box of what religion and I'm telling
you no no nobody's saying that yes yes
you want to put me in a box you want to
divide what is being reflected is
indivisible all religions and I don't
want to create Division I don't want to
say I'm a Christian or I don't want to
say I'm a Muslim I want to say I'm your
sister
whatever I am
your is
to respect there's a little Glimpse
there you know that's that's spiritual
right you know's a little Glimpse these
days is very corrupt they do channeling
they're they're saying things that are
completely not true so I don't want to
put myself in the box of spiritual I
understand what you're saying not even
the box of spirituality and I wish you
the best but you need some help yeah for
sure other than that see and that's
where we'll wrap is where the
very um Reflection from that which is
contracted right in this case fresh is
saying you need
help and that's a very common thing is
that there's a projection a very strong
projection from
separation that you need help because
you're feeling
indivisibility you're feeling the
Oneness and
you're uh
channeling
indivisibility and building new Earth
from this place of indivisibility
building the new from a place of love
and abundance and prosperity for all
building new communi
that are so gorgeous and
Indescribable with modern Energy Systems
housing systems food water Sovereign
systems you know exiting the Matrix and
building those new that new
world and you're so clearly a selfless
channel of that to those that are of the
same vibration that can see it but for
those that are still contracted living
in a world of
Separation that comes off as so
threatening because there's been an
identification with that in this case
fresh or any of anyone there that's on
that panel is there such a strong
identification with separation with with
the name with
the with the feeling of being separate
that any reflection of indivisible
ability is immediately said you need
help you need help because I can't let
go of my identification with being
separate so that's pretty much that's
pretty much it I wanted to do this
breakdown because it's just a perfect
example of what happens when
the Matrix of
separation and also the Matrix
of of
lack when it collides with some a force
that is
indivisible and it's
clearly
threatening the feeling of being
separate so it's a perfect colliding of
the feeling of separation and the
obviousness of indivisibility and
Oneness and so it's a be it was a
beautiful colliding of that in that
specific segment of the
podcast so very beautiful and I wanted
to support my friend and I really am so
excited about the new Earth and this
these are the types of conversations
that are so crucial for the new Earth
because there is no division there is no
separation there is only Oneness there
is is only that and from that place be
yourself from the place of non
separation be yourself whatever your
unique gifts are bring them to the world
but from that place of non-separation
There's No Lack there's no un wholeness
there's no unfulfillment and therefore
you're creating from a place of
wholeness from always wholeness so
therefore you can focus all of your time
energy attention effort on building new
Earth there's zero time attention energy
that is siphoned away because of that
illus illusion of Separation that then
feels unfulfillment and lack and is
always seeking and
objectifying whatever experiences or
objects that it's
chasing you see so it's just such a
perfect Collision of separation and
Oneness and to just Inspire through this
to have this type of conversation more
about building new Earth about the
indivisibility about the Oneness about
love thanks for tuning
in
and
yeah just the magic truly the
magic all
right